Mind Your Decisions, I'm Presh Talwalkar
Find the coefficient of x to the power of nine in the expansion of the following binomial product
The first term is 1 plus x
multiplied by 1 plus x squared
Multiplied by 1 plus x cubed all the way until the last term of 1 plus x to the power of 100
This was asked on the Jee Advanced exam which is a test used for admission into India's prestigious IIT colleges
Pause the video if you'd like to give it a try. And when you're ready keep watching to learn how to solve this problem.
Let's analyze this binomial product
Consider the term 1 plus x to the power of 10
What happens if we multiply x to the power of 10 by ones in all of the other binomial terms?
We'll end up with x to the power of 10
Notice the exponent is larger than x to the power of 9
So this will not contribute to the coefficient of x to the power of 9
similarly, if we have 1 plus x to the power of k where k is greater than 9. If we multiply this by all of
the 1 terms in all of the other binomials we'll end up with a term
that is an exponent that's larger than x to the power of 9
So we don't need to focus on any of these terms to get the coefficient of x to the power of 9
We'll only go up to 1 plus x to the power of 9 and then we'll distribute this term with all the other ones in all of the other binomials.
So let's analyze this binomial product
We will recall an exponent rule
x to the power of A multiplied by x to the power B is equal to x to the power of A plus B
We are therefore going to count the ways that the exponents sum to 9 and the exponents are the numbers from 1 to 9
We'll then multiply the result by ones from all of the other binomials in the product
Now here's a simple observation: 1+2+3+4 = 10 and that's greater than 9
So we can only have 3, 2, or 1 terms in the product
If we have 4 terms, we're gonna get to an exponent that's larger than 9
So let's enumerate the ways
If we have one term, we just have x to the power of 9
For two terms we can have 8 + 1. We can have 7 + 2. We can have 6 + 3,  or we can have 5 + 4.
What about three terms?
One way is 6 + 2 + 1
Another way is 5 + 3 + 1. And a final way is 4 + 3 + 2
There's no other way to get to a power of 9
Interestingly the problem relates to number theory because these are the partitions of the number 9 from the set 1 through 9.
We count these and there are a total of 8 ways. And that's the answer.
Just for fun we can input this into Wolfram Alpha and it will verify that the answer is 8
Incredible
Thanks for making Mind Your Decisions one of the best channels on YouTube
As always, thanks for watching and thanks for your support